on ne va pas se mentir cet outil m'aide
beaucoup dans la réalisation des vidéos
grâce à ça je peux voir ou revoir la
plupart des films disponibles partout
dans le monde sans bouger de chez moi
effectivement cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par north vpn il y a quelques jours dr
strange in the multiverse of madness est
sorti sur dix n'est plus grâce à notre
vpn et en un seul clic j'ai pu le revoir
en détail en changeant ma localisation
pour le canada ou la belgique par
exemple car oui malheureusement en
france nous n'avons pas accès à toutes
les productions disponibles dans le
monde et nord européenne peut vous
permettre de contourner tout ça c'est
quand même agréable de se dire que
seulement un mois et demi après la
sortie de doctor strange de au cinéma je
peux le revoir tranquillou chez moi dans
mon canapé grâce à north bay pn et ce
sera le cas aussi pour thor 4 qui sort
très prochainement il arrivera très
certainement sur dix n'est plus aux
alentours de fin août début septembre
bref non vpn est un outil très sécurisé
vous protégeant notamment contre les
criminels et la surveillance sur le web
ce dernier est accessible via six
appareils différents et possède une
excellente vitesse d'exécution grâce à
ses cinq mille 200 serveurs répartis
dans 60 pays si vous êtes intéressés par
nos épées n hésitez pas à accéder au
lien disponible en descriptions norvez
pn vous propose une offre inédite de
deux ans d'abonnement avec une réduction
de plus de 60 9% et 1 mois offerts
satisfait ou remboursé sur 30 jours
merci beaucoup à noordpeene pour leur
confiance que la vidéo commence
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo dédiée à
doctor strange de et l'avenir du mca
effectivement vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que le film vient de sortir sur
le disney + us et belges notamment et du
coup bah ça m'a permis de le revoir et
notamment de revoir plusieurs scènes
importantes du film donc désormais nous
allons pouvoir en reparler en détails et
je peux vous assurer qu'il y a plein de
choses intéressantes a souligné henno
tamment a théorisé multiverse of madness
est clairement un ciment pour la phase
iv et nous donne plusieurs directions
pour la phase 5 est du coup le futur de
marvel une phase qui sera beaucoup plus
concrète et moins dans les oreilles jean
story alors bien évidemment nous ferons
plusieurs vidéos sur doctor strange il
ya notamment une thématique très forte
qui tissent d'ailleurs pas mal de choses
pour l'avenir et dont j'aimerais vous
parler mais voilà ça sera ça ce sera
l'objet d'une prochaine vidéo ce
week-end si tout se passe bien
normalement je devrais vous sortir
pourquoi dormammu est si unique donc
voilà un deuxième épisode qui cette fois
ci sera centré sur dormammu et je peux
vous assurer qu'il ya plein
d'informations intéressantes et on va
revoir certaines choses je pense dans
l'avenir du mc mais bref aujourd'hui
j'aimerais que l'on se concentre avant
tout sur la thématique des incursions
c'est une menace énorme pour l'avenir de
marvel alors à la base je voulais vous
sortir cette vidéo il ya quand même un
bon moment je suis désolé pour le retard
vous commencez à avoir l'habitude mais
voilà vu que le film est sorti nous
avons désormais toutes les cartes en
main je vous avoue que quand j'ai vu
multiverse hoffmann s pour la première
fois quand ils ont parlé de la
thématique des incursions ça m'a
vraiment inquiété car les incursions
c'est vraiment
un sacré bordel on va dire les termes je
sais que beaucoup de spectateurs du mc
vue commence un peu à lâcher prise par
moments notamment parce que cela se
complexifie dans la saga le scénario et
caetera et surtout bas il faut suivre de
fous les oeuvres je me souviens
notamment de la critique faite par
rapport à doctor strange 2 comme quoi il
fallait voir plusieurs films comme dr
strange nos héros mais serra et en plus
fallait voir la série howard davies y
ont donc voila vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire mais du coup les incursions
bas cela va pas aider à simplifier tout
ça quoi mais bon je suis là aussi pour
vous accompagner et vous expliquer
l'univers de marvel donc on va voir tout
ça ensemble et je pense que vous allez
comprendre pourquoi le phénomène des
incursions me grattait la tête bon pour
commencer rentrons dans le dur qu'est ce
qu'une incursion on va se baser sur les
comics car après tout tout vient de là
bas l'origine le mc us en inspire même
si bien évidemment il y aura des
réécritures tous possèdent un début et
une fin la naissance jusqu'à la mort et
cela concerne aussi le multivers il y à
la naissance de l'univers puis vient la
naissance de la terre des planètes et
cetera puis à terme bien évidemment la
terre va mourir ainsi que tout ce qu'il
y a dans l'univers puis ce dernier va
s'effondrer et mourir de par le
multivers nous savons qu'il existe une
multitude d'univers rempiler avec pour
chacun sa propre timeline mais tous ces
univers sont plus ou moins relier il
possède le même début la même naissance
et par conséquent ils possèdent la même
finalité la fin de toute chose la fin du
multivers et c'est là que les incursions
entre en jeu les incursions symbolise
une contraction dans la timeline du
multivers une contraction qui va
engendrer la mort d'un univers où
plusieurs ce qui va accélérer la fin du
multivers et par conséquent la mort de
tout ce qui existe et pour être plus
précis cette contraction va engendrer la
collision de deux univers qui vont
s'entrechoquer et s'autodétruire sachant
que pour chaque incursion il ya toujours
ce qu'on appelle un point d'incursions
c'est à dire l'endroit où les univers
vont entrer en vision est d'ailleurs
avant que les univers s'entrechoquent il
existe toujours une période d'alignement
parfaite où les points d'incursion de
chaque univers existe au même endroit
sans aucun problème ce qui fait que l'on
peut apercevoir le point d'incursion de
l'autre univers depuis son univers et
vous pouvez même y accéder sans problème
bref c'est du détail mais voilà la base
de la base d'une incursion par rapport
au mc eu et plus particulièrement dr
strange 2 le concept semble être
exactement la même chose que dans les
comics reed richards alias monsieur
fantastique nous affirme que les
incursions s'enclenche quand la
frontière entre deux univers suse et
finissent par entrer en collision
découlant sur la destruction totale de
l'un ou des deux univers et c'est un
point intéressant car effectivement
comment stopper une incursion eh bien
cela ne semble pas réellement possible
on ne peut pas vraiment stopper une
incursion en revanche on peut diminuer
la casse quand reid affirme que
l'aboutissement d'une incursion c'est la
destruction d'un ou des deux univers
impliqués et bien en fait il nous
confirme ce qui est apportée dans les
comics c'est d'ailleurs la thématique
principale des comics sicre et wars qui
font beaucoup parler d'eux dernièrement
pour se sortir d'une incursion il existe
la solution d'annuler l'univers d'en
face pour éviter qu'ils entrent en
collision ce qui permettra la survie
dans des deux univers c'est pourquoi
sicre et wars existe et qu'il ya des
guerres dans les incursions car chaque
réalité tentera de défendre son
territoire et d'annihiler celui d'en
face pour sa survie et c'est ce qui nous
est expliqué dans doctor strange de
viale suprême dr strange le suprême dr
strange a voulu la jouer solo et tu es
thanos tout seul sauf qu'il a fait
quelques d'un gris avec le dard gold
notamment des rêves passerelle et cela a
provoqué la naissance d'une incursion
entre sa réalité la 838 est une autre
seul à faire face à ce problème or il
nous dit que ce trench n'a pas apporté
plus de détails quant il a convoqué les
illuminati mais son erreur a entraîné la
destruction totale de l'univers d'en
face tuant donc des three lions d'êtres
vivants et du coup cela va nous
permettre de rebondir sur une question
que l'on pause tout ce qu'est ce qui va
provoquer une incursion et bien je vous
avoue que la question est délicate car
dans les comics cela reste plutôt flou
et bien sûr comme d'habitude les comics
ça monte hyper vite hyper loin c'est
ultra crescendo on fait face à une vraie
escalade de conséquences donc voilà pour
les films et les séries il y aura une
réécriture et une réadaptation pour
simplifier tout ça quoi sécrétoire nous
introduit les incursions puis c'est
directement un effet domino où les
univers entre en collision de partout
jusqu'à ce que le multivers soit
anéantie il n'y a clairement pas de
limites on nous présente le phénomène
d'incursions et juste après nous sommes
rendus à l'annulation totale du
multivers et c'est justifié notamment
par le fait que plus lien d'incursions
plus les destructions d'univers
s'accélère et donc de plus en plus
d'incursions arrive et plus la fin de
tout s'accélère aussi et bien évidemment
tout ça est provoqué par le docteur doom
qui multiplie les incursions dans les
comics du coup les incursions sont
l'oeuvre à la base des billes under une
race extraterrestre ultra cosmique ultra
supérieur et tout ce qui s'ensuit en
gros ces derniers font des expériences
avec l'humanité et voix après leurs
résultats ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
qu'ils ont créé une singularité dans
chaque univers par le biais d'un homme
appelé molécules man alias owen rhys en
gros le but était que ce dernier soit
une bombe à retardement
c'est à dire que dès que le personnage
va mourir et ce dans chaque univers il
emportera avec lui la mort de son
univers et cela permettra d'aboutir à la
fin du multivers l'origine des
incursions a donc été amené par le
docteur doom ainsi qu'un molécules man
qui ont voyagé 25 ans dans le passé d'un
autre univers en tuant le mollet
kullmann de ce monde bref tout ça c'est
vraiment hyper complexe et je ne pense
pas du tout que ce sera adapté à l'écran
car c'est vraiment un délire ou doom
essaye de devancer les billons d'earth
d'acquérir leur pouvoir et profiter de
l'effondrement inévitable du multivers
pour le relancer et du coup donné
naissance à battle ou out voilà ce n'est
pas simple du tout quoi en revanche ce
qui est intéressant c'est que même si
c'est relié de fou aux billes under et
bien on retrouve quand même à peu près
le même délire dans le mca dans le sens
où l'origine d'une incursion est le
résultat naturel d'une action ou d'une
empreinte d'une entité dans un autre
univers le suprême strange a fait des
dingueries dans d'autres univers et cela
a donné naissance à une acura sur les
dodgers est très inquiet de la présence
de strange america chavez dans l'univers
838 car à chaque pas effectué par les
protagonistes il y a une chance que ces
derniers créent une incursion en fait si
vous laisser une emprunte trop forte
dans un univers dont vous n'êtes pas
originaire et bien c'est là que la
contraction va se créer en théorie nous
ne sommes pas censés réellement aller
dans d'autres univers et du coup quand
cela se produit c'est comme une sorte de
bugs dans la matrice et par conséquent
il ya une réaction qui survient l'ordre
naturel des choses souhaite alors
corriger le tir d'une certaine manière
néanmoins cela ne semble pas être si
simpliste que ça dans le sens où si on
suit à la lettre le concept d'incursions
et bien cela voudrait dire que la
réalité que nous suivons la 616 devrait
rentrer en collision avec la réalité de
tobey maguire et celle d'andrew garfield
en soit par rapport à nos héros mme et
c'est pareil pour l'univers de sony avec
venom ou carrément le vautour qui a
atterri chez mort bus il semblerait du
coup que comme l'a démontré multiverse
of madness avec les trois dr strange les
incursions s'enclenche plus facilement à
cause d'une empreinte magique très forte
dans un autre univers typiquement
l'utilisation du dark auld et des rêves
passerait et c'est là que l'on va
pouvoir s'amuser un petit peu et
théorisé cela va me permettre de donner
mon point de vue et mes idées déjà par
rapport à notre dr strange la fin du
film nous introduit cléa à l'écran la
nièce de dormammu originaire de la
dimension noir cette dernière nous
affirme que doctor strange a causé une
incursion dans l'univers 616 que nous
suivons et qu'ils doivent aller la
réparer deux choses intéressantes ici a
souligné premièrement comme je vous
disais il n'est pas vraiment possible de
réparer entre guillemets une incursion
normalement donc cela veut dire que pour
le mc eu marvel studios a une idée
derrière la tête ensuite ces étonnantes
se dire que celui qui a causé une
incursion dans son univers c'est docteur
strange et non wendat rwanda est
clairement la menace du film c'est elle
qui a fait énormément de dinguerie avant
tout et même les illuminati l'ignorent à
la base car pour eux la véritable menace
du multivers c dr strange et bien tout
ça ce n'est pas incohérent et marvel
semble nous avoir amené en sous marin la
preuve de l'existence des êtres nexus
one da est un nexus bing est la plus
connue d'ailleurs lui étant donné que
multiverse of madness nous a confirmé
que la réalité que nous suivons et la
616 bomba dans les comics rwanda est le
nexus bing de la réalité 616 mais du
coup qu'est ce qu'un être nexus ou nexus
bling et bien dans l'univers marvel il
existe des êtres qui sont beaucoup trop
puissant tellement puissants qu'ils
peuvent piller la réalité comme bon leur
semble et aux influences et les
probabilités du futur c'est le cas de
wendat par exemple luanda est tellement
puissante car elle est la scarlet witch
débordante de magie du chaos qu'elle
peut faire ce qu'elle veut et ce sans
forcément avoir de conséquences derrière
par exemple dans le mc eu west view
rwanda a carrément créé un univers
alternatif où elle contrôlait tous et
qu'elle a refermé par la suite et comme
on l'a vu dans multiverse of madness il
n'a pas vraiment eu de conséquence à ce
qu'elle a fait et wendat pourtant elle
enchaîne les dingueries son lieu de vie
a été corrompue par ses nombreuses
expériences par le biais du dard gold
elle a effectué un rêve passerelle pour
attraper america chavez elle a même tué
des gens le biais de créatures multi
vercel et pourtant rien aucune
conséquence c dr strange qui a causé une
incursion et non rwanda et bien ce
serait par rapport à sa condition d'être
nexus une condition qui l'arrangent
centrale dans le multivers elle peut
faire ce qu'elle veut l'univers suivra
le flux temporel s'adaptera même si ce
n'était pas prévu et nous en sommes
d'ailleurs témoins dans le film elle n'a
pas de tribu à faire audard gold bon et
du coup pour revenir à strange et cléa
c'est plutôt intriguant de relier la
protagoniste au phénomène des incursions
car dans les comics il n'y a vraiment
aucun rapport clé à n'est pas du tout
relié aux incursions et pourtant ils
nous disent le contraire dans le mc eu
pourquoi cela personnellement et vous
aurez plus de réponse à cette question
dans les deux prochaines vidéos mais je
pense que c'est lié au concept des
dimensions et notamment dormammu spoiler
alert cléa c'est pas du tout une
antagonistes et c'est même les pouces et
la disciple de dr strange dans les
comics et dès sa première apparition
dans le comics strange tales 126 elle
vient en aide à dr strange et le met en
garde concernant dormammu en sortant du
film pour la première fois je me disais
que si marvel avait décidé de relier
cléa et les incursions c'était peut-être
par rapport à dormammu et du coup son
royaume la dimension noir peut être par
peur que tout s'effondre que dormammu a
peur de perdre son royaume à cause de
l'annihilation de l'univers en gros mais
j'avoue je sais pas j'avoue
qu'aujourd'hui je doute car les
dimensions un fonctionnement particulier
ce n'est pas comme les univers où les
multis vert il se pourrait même que
dormammu profitent de l'incursion pour
ses plans mais en même temps c'est très
flou il faut voir quels sont les
véritables intentions de clea dans le mc
si on respecte les comics elle
interviendrait pour aider strange
qu'elle a dû observer depuis un certain
temps mais aussi parce qu'elle serait
inquiète pour son peuple qui vit dans la
dimension noir donc à voir nous allons
en reparler en détail prochainement
enfin il y a un gros mystère dont il
faut que nous parlions et qui est en
lien avec les incursions et c'est très
clairement je pense le plus gros sujet à
théorie de multivers of madness comme
vous le savez durant le film docteur
strange va atterrir dans la réalité du
sinistre strange la réalité du sinister
est rempli de mystères car en soi
d'après la scène d'arrivée de strange et
christine on nous fait comprendre que la
réalité a subi une incursion la scène
d'arriver dans la réalité est clairement
une scène d'exposition c'est à dire une
scène qui va permettre de décrire aux
spectateurs le pourquoi du comment de
façon subtile par le biais des dialogues
donc voilà si c'est la 6 et a mené par
strange et christine ce n'est pas pour
rien mais en même temps rien ne prouve
véritablement que la réalité a subi une
incursion le sinister strange reste flou
sur le sujet et il nous parle notamment
de tribus pour le dard claude ensuite
élément surprenant le sinistre strange
nous apprend qu'ils possèdent très
similairement la même histoire que notre
docteur strange il nous parle du fait
d'être heureux qu'il a menti à christine
par rapport à ça qu'il était à son
mariage bref exactement comme notre
docteur strange est là du coup c'est
très intrigant car le sinistre strange
après avoir utilisé le dark auld après
avoir subi la parution de son troisième
oeil son univers est entré en collision
et a été annihilée sauf que de l'autre
côté eh bien c'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer pour notre dr
strange il a lui aussi utilisé le dard
cold lui aussi il a fait un rêve
passerelle il l'a le troisième oeil et
maintenant son univers rentrer en
collision avec un autre donc c'est pour
nous tease et du lourd la prochaine fois
que l'on va retrouver notre strange ce
sera pour affronter l'incursion sauf que
cela ne s'arrête pas là car le sinistre
strange nous dévoile qu'il l'a perdue
durant sa possible incursion ce à quoi
notre strange va répondre perdre face à
qui est le sinistre strange va changer
de sujet pourquoi ne pas avoir dévoilé
contre qui le sinister strange a perdu
pourquoi amener cette question et la
laisser en suspens sans nous donner de
réponse eh bien je pense que c'est parce
que cela cache quelque chose bien
évidemment au premier abord on pourrait
se dire que le sinister strange a en
fait perdu face aux suprêmes strange qui
a déclenché une incursion est annihilée
l'univers d'en face nous aurions un
gagnant et un perdant et voilà mais je
ne sais pas vous mais perso je vois pas
pourquoi ils n'auraient pas donné
l'information dans le film comme quoi la
réalité du sinistre strange est rentrée
en collision avec celle du suprême il
n'y a pas de secret concernant ceux ci
il n'y a rien à cacher donc perso je
pense que c'est vraiment parce que c'est
quelque chose de gros derrière tout ça
un teasing pour l'avenir du mca on ne
nous dit pas qui a gagné contre le
sinistre strange tout simplement car
cela va servir pour le futur et
peut-être même qu'on nous le dit pas car
au vu de la similitude entre les
histoires des strange eh bien peut-être
que notre docteur strange va faire face
à cette même menace avec sa propre
incursion quoi là moi je vous avoue
qu'avec tous ces éléments il n'y a pas
36 possibilités en soit peut-être que
cela n'a rien à voir peut-être que
l'incursion causés par strange opposera
la réalité 616 à la 838 de par son
voyage là bas mais bon étant donné que
les illuminati sont morts je ne vois pas
trop l'utilité scénaristique sinon nous
pourrions nous dire que l'incursion sera
peut-être en lien avec l'univers du
defender strange dont on nous a dévoilé
qu'il venait de la réalité 617 puisque
dr strange fait un rêve passerelle avec
son corps dans la réalité 616 donc voilà
mais bref ce n'est pas trop là où je
voulais en venir il se pourrait que
celui qui a causé la défaite du sinistre
strange et qui par conséquent a causé
l'annulation de sa réalité et bien
ce serait
kang le conquérant alors oui je sais
j'adore qu'anglo conquérant on en parle
très souvent si je ne prononce pas le
nom de kangoo conquérant dans une vidéo
je ne respire plus mais bon en vrai
c'est tout à fait plausible
nous le savons nous commençons arrivé au
terme de la phase 4 comme l'a déclaré
kevin fait guy ce qui signifie comme il
le dit lui-même que nous allons enfin
savoir à peu près où nous allons nous
diriger c'est à dire finie la mise en
place fini les origin story en veux tu
en voilà nous allons enfin rentrer dans
du concret et une direction kang a été
teasé dans la série low-kick ang est un
conquérant du multivers et du temps qui
a d'ailleurs causé et vécu la guerre
multi vercel et nous l'attendons tous à
devenir à un super vilain aussi iconique
et présent que thanos et pour rappel
thanos ils l'ont tease et pendant
longtemps et toutes les thématiques du
mc eu étaient reliés de près ou de loin
à ce dernier les avengers dans les
premières phases ont été liés aux
pierres qui sont reliés à l'objectif de
thanos nous avons eu camorra nebula les
filles de thanos il y a eu la présence
de l'eau qui est rhône ain qui agissait
au nom de thanos bref énormément
d'éléments et de thématiques étaient
reliés à ce dernier jusqu'à son
apparition ultime eh bien là c'est
pareil avec la phase 4 on nous amène le
tva avec les time keepers les ennemis de
gangs dans les comics au final dans
l'uem cu cele remains une identité
similaires aïe mortueux et identité
futur de celles de quang on nous amène
la guerre multi vercel le multivers lui
même on sait très bien que quand c'est
un conquérant du multivers du style il
cherche à conquérir le plus de
temporalité de dimension et d'univers il
est l'un des plus grands ennemis des
avengers et les a déjà confronté
plusieurs fois là avec les incursions
bas c'est clairement l'introduction des
guerres multi vers celle où deux univers
doivent s'affronter jusqu'à la mort pour
leur survie donc qu'amd pourrait être
clairement reliés à sa du style il a
profité de l'incursion causés par le
sinistre strange pour annihiler sa
réalité car le sinister aurait pourquoi
pas causer une incursion avec un univers
où kangs est partie en conquête de l'ère
moderne et pas de chance pour le
sinister sa route aurait croisé celle de
quang contre qui il n'a rien pu faire et
sa réalité a fini détruites ça se trouve
il a même peut être négocié sa survie
face à quang afin de rester l'unique
survivant de sa réalité puisque de toute
façon il veut la quitter pour une autre
où il serait avec christine palmer en
soit tout est possible on ne peut se
baser sur rien et du coup cela permet
encore une fois de relier toutes
ensemble et du coup de relier strange et
cléa à quang le conquérant et d'ailleurs
comme je le disais quand je cherche
aussi à conquérir les dimensions par
exemple dans les comics il conquit la
dimension de ramona la princesse d'un
royaume situé dans une petite dimension
du coup si marvel fait le choix par
exemple de ramener dormammu et la
dimension noir par le biais de clea via
multiverse of madness et bien qu'amd
pourrait être une menace pour la
dimension noir en souhaitant la
conquérir tout est possible dans le mc
eu mais quand on regarde de plus près
tout est plus ou moins liés à kong si
marvel décide d'adapter sécrétoire à
l'écran kang pourrait clairement prendre
le rôle de docteur doom avec les
incursions car si on réfléchit un petit
peu remains et doctor doom ont fait
similairement la même chose doctor doom
a accéléré et causé d'innombrables
incursion pour qu'à la fin il ne reste
plus rien et comme ça il peut relancer
qu'un seul univers à son image battle
world et women's lui a fait
similairement la même chose il a utilisé
à la hausse pour terminer la guerre
multi vercel et qu'il ne reste qu'un
flux temporel qui l'a isolé
et voilà en vrai j'ai beau cherché mais
je trouve qu'il n'ya pas plus sexy et
attrayant que kong pour être celui qui a
causé la défaite du sinistre strange
après cela pourrait clairement être
quelqu'un d'autre un je ne dis pas
contraires mais pour le moment je ne
vois pas qui cela aurait pu être
pourquoi pas un autre docteur strange
mais bon je ne vois pas l'utilité de
garder ça secret de ne pas répondre à la
question du coût dans tous les cas
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
on a essayé d'analyser de théoriser un
petit peu plus en profondeur a vous de
me dire du coup en commentaire ce que
vous en avez pensé et qu'elles sont du
coup vos théories par rapport à tout ça
il ya vraiment plein de choses à dire
sur multiverse of madness donc soyez en
sûr on va en reparler en attendant
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de vous
abonner à la chaîne dit rousseff qui m'a
accompagné sur cette vidéo on se
retrouve normalement ce week-end pour la
vidéo dédiée à dormammu et puis bah
écoute et que le lionheart soit avec
vous c'était un argot rock allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]